if you align yourself with one way of  thinking one ideology one group it means  you you are literally Outsourcing your  thinking to someone else and you're  saying I will never think for myself  again I mean you may as well kill  yourself at that point what's the point  seriously what's the point in being  alive if you're just going to say  someone else do my thinking for me  priest you tell me what to think about  the world but these are intelligent  people these are ivy league graduates it  doesn't matter I mean people people are  Ivy League schools can be really stupid  and particularly now that so many higher  education institutions are effectively  just churning out ideological nonsense  and just attempting to train people to  think a certain way they're not really  universities anymore are there any  Universities in name as far as I can see